content marketers who have a documented
strategy or consistently seem to be more
effective a written strategy can bring
cohesion to an otherwise complex process
of creating marketing content it's vital
to create a systematic method of
creating content and it's equally vital
to measure the effectiveness of your
efforts so in this module we're going to
look at how to structure your documented
strategy so that you're able to provide
proof of concept to your upper
management and so that your team is
ready to execute on this plan
efficiently after completing this module
you should be able to do the following
one outline the steps needed to create a
content strategy for your organization
to describe the importance of various
parts of a Content plan including
listening measuring assigning tasks and
securing budget three choose the
channels that are most suitable to
complement your content and finally
prioritize and plan content ideas around
your company's biggest opportunities
yeah you might have to hammer out some
company content marketing processes and
you need to understand that they're
going to mutate over time there's going
to be the launch process and then then
there's a sort of the early adoption
process and then there may be a mature
process don't get hung up on the fact
that your processes are going to change
they will they will certainly change as
you get feedback on what worked and what
didn't but it's good to sort of hammer
that out and understand that it will
evolve because one of the things that
you may need to create is a playbook why
because you not only need buy-in from
top management you may also need
collaboration from some of the other
parts of the marketing department down
the hall and to the extent that you can
say look this is the strategy and here's
where you fit and this is the piece that
you know we need to collaborate on your
going to be a lot more successful sooner
that's why a documented content strategy
is one of the secret secret formulas for
becoming an effective content marketer
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos to nerd out and get
certified in digital marketing click
here